I'm joined today by Ben Bergen who is a
professor of cognitive science and
director of the language and cognition
lab at the University of California San
Diego he's the author most recently of
what the f what swearing reveals about
our language our brains and our selves I
bet it's so great to have you on I want
to talk about sort of two general topics
one how profanity effects brains and
also how profanity affects children
which has really become a pretty big
political debate in this country so
first I guess broadly speaking should we
distinguish between sort of isolated
swear words and actual slurs that have
sort of more social meaning when we're
talking about the impact of these words
is that an important distinction to make
yeah when you look at the empirical
evidence on how language affects people
that includes kids and adults there's a
difference between verbal abuse and that
includes use of slurs to you know
denigrate people based on their race
ethnicity religion sex sexual
orientation and so on or to threaten
people uh to denigrate them there's a
difference between that type of language
which is known to cause long-term
effects increased depression anxiety it
actually leads people to act in a more
discriminatory way towards members of
those marginalized groups on the one
hand you've got that type of language
and then on the other hand you have the
sort of fleeting expletives that come
about in everyday life and these if you
look again at sort of the distribution
of these in real life you find that
people use profanity for lots of things
other than abuse in fact most of the
things that people used prevent before
are for positive pro-social reasons like
to alleviate pain or to express
frustration or to cement informal social
relations with a person to seem powerful
to seem accessible to be funny and and
so those uses of the very same words
serve a different purpose and they have
different consequences on people's
brains
bodies so we really do want to keep them
apart so let's talk first about sort of
these isolated expletives right words
that have been determined to be you know
a good framework in the u.s. to think
about is FCC regulations and sort of
words that are on a list which can't or
shouldn't be said if an if a program or
channel wants to avoid fines how do
those words sort of come about as words
that better considered bad words
historically how does it happen socially
how does it happen and is there some
element of sort of society giving these
words more power by putting them on
these arbitrary lists yeah that's
exactly how it works so if you look
across the world's languages most of
them have something like an idea that
there are certain words that are bad
that are taboo that are profane and
across the world's languages you find
that these words overwhelmingly tend to
come from one of four major sources they
tend to be drawn from words that at
their origin have religious meetings
that have meanings related to sex
meanings related to bodily functions in
general and then meetings related to
other social groups usually marginalized
social groups and specific ones of those
of those groups specific words from
those categories will come to be over
time decided upon by a social group as
the words that are the bad ones and so
you can think about for example lots of
words about sex that are absolutely
profane and that you would get fined for
for using on television or radio and
lots of other words that would be the
type of thing that you would use with
your therapist or your doctor or maybe
even with children when you're
explaining the birds and the bees so
it's not the it's not the meaning that
they had at their origin that is the
determiner that they will be ultimately
decided as as profane it's a contributor
what has to happen is exactly what you
said that people have to decide well
this particular word it makes me
uncomfortable it makes me feel like it
could cause harm to children or whatever
reason maybe the way that it sounds and
and as a result by implementing sort of
social control on the use of those words
you're right that censorship
is one type of social control but it
happens in in the home and in the
classroom as well when a child is
punished for using a word when the soap
comes out for example or when children
are told that you know this word is
really not appropriate for for school or
when parents react in a very strong
emotional way the child is learning that
this word is a powerful word it has
impact I can use it to control my
environment including my parents and
other adults and that's a really
exciting thing for a child and it's a
lesson that they learn implicitly that
then carries with them for their entire
life so the words that we now think of
as profane the words that now have
physiological impact on us as adults we
uh we only learned that they were
powerful because of those social
controls that were implemented early on
in our lives do we have researcher data
that tells us anything about the sort of
social impact of uh being in a in a
country for example where swearing is
just generally less of a big deal in my
personal sort of references that I'm
from Argentina and on television and
radio in Argentina swearing is just not
really a big deal even to some degree
nudity on television outside of the
so-called safe harbor hours that exist
here in the US it's not really a big
deal and I'd be interested to know if we
have any data about how this impacts and
it could be children it could be adults
or just any anybody yeah great question
well you're right that there's huge
variation from culture to culture in how
how strictly the regulations are imposed
on on specific language so on one end of
the scale you have places like like
Afghanistan where where lass famiy is a
capital offense on the other hand you
have something like so Argentina i think
is a pretty good example may be an even
more extreme example would be something
like france where even the strongest
words show up in the mouths of children
and the mouths of teachers and then the
mouths of the President of the Republic
on the floor of the Senate so there's
much less there's a much less strict
relationship to language in those
societies and I'd say that in the United
States were
somewhere in between probably closer to
France than Afghanistan in that we have
some social controls that we impose we
don't really know what the differences
are in the effects on on children so we
can't say for example that in
Afghanistan children are more aggressive
because profanity is stronger because
there are so many other variables across
cultures that go into affecting things
like childhood well-being their
psychological state their their physical
well-being and all that all that sort of
stuff so it's sort of an it's an
uncontrolled experiment we can't really
know but but we certainly know that for
people who speak languages where there
is more social control present speakers
of those languages experience strong or
physiological reactions to the profane
words of their language so we know that
there's something about those early
childhood and continuing experiences
what we're told these are bad words we
may engender really strong emotional
reactions and other people we
internalize that we we internalize that
into our bodies such that our our heart
rates increase our palm start sweating
and so on whenever we're exposed to one
of those words when we talk now about
slurs versus swears let's let's dig into
that a little bit I mean what what can
we say distinguishes the impact of maybe
not only the hearing of but also the
normalization of whether they be racial
ethnic religious gender etcetera slurs
uh it could be on children but also more
generally in society as as you sort of
alluded to at the beginning of the
interview that's a whole different ball
game isn't it of course yeah so there's
some good social psychology evidence
that even merely overhearing a slur even
unconsciously will affect the way that
you treat people in that marginalized
group so I can talk about a couple of
experiments in one people were
subconsciously presented with a
homophobic slur and in the control
condition they were presented again
unconsciously with the word homosexual
and after that they didn't know that
they had actually been exposed to this
word because it was it was displayed so
quickly on the screen
15 milliseconds faster than you can
consciously apprehend they were a get
been asked to perform some tasks one of
the tasks was they were told to go into
another room and to set up some chairs
for a conversation they were going to
have with another student at the
University who was a homosexual and and
and what the experimenters measured was
how far apart the participants put those
two chairs and what they found was that
people who had been primed with the
homophobic slur positioned their chairs
about 10 centimeters farther apart than
the people who had been primed with the
word homosexual so there's something
about this slur that's physically
driving people apart it's leading people
to not want to be close to homosexuals
in this particular case you also see
economic discrimination so people again
who are subconsciously exposed to these
homophobic slurs decide that when when
asked how resources should be allocated
at the level of the government decide
that less money should go to AIDS and
HIV prevention than people who were
primed with with the word homosexual so
there's a lot of there's a lot of
downstream consequences for merely
overhearing or overseeing these these
words and we also know that at least in
correlational studies kids who are
called by slurs again mostly homophobic
slurs have been studied um display the
greatest decreases over the course of
Middle School in their emotional
well-being so the kids who report being
called things like homo and lesbo and
and slurs like that also report that
over the course of 6th and 7th and 8th
grades they they show that they have a
greatest increase in depression anxiety
and feelings of detachment from their
schools so there's a lot of sort of
convergent evidence that slurs can be
harmful now that's not to say that they
always are slurs can be used in positive
ways as well and a lot of them get
reappropriation groups who are
marginalized by them but that's sort of
a more complicated wrinkle well I think
it will not come as a surprise to many
of our progressive viewers that the
focus of the religious right on isolated
words that shouldn't be said
versus real ways in which people are
sort of being insulted uh may not be the
right focus if we're trying to increase
well-being overall I think many in our
audience will will say well yes David uh
we've been speaking about the book what
the f what swearing reveals about our
language our brains in ourselves we've
been speaking with the book's author
professor ben bergen thank you so much
for talking to us about this it's my
pleasure thanks so much